yes hello welcome back to art
appreciation with Chris Redfield here we
have Bosch's 1762 painting yellow black
spider hole in it now at the Louvre it's
coming - hi everybody hey hi everyone
hey hey Mary seems like something like
like a Banksy project
Studio tech we're in our other stream
studio because we are recording earlier
in the day on a Friday it's gonna be a
semi short episode compared to normal
we got a boss fight to get to I think
cuz I I remember like seeing to a degree
I remember seeing like oh it looked like
a wall or something made of slime I
remember I know where we are I was a
staff member like I I saved and then as
we were leaving I was like I'm gonna
check out what's going on ahead and
there was like 4,000 zombies and then
like a wall of something and I don't I
didn't really see it but it looked gross
so I know I need a lot of firepower and
I know I need at least like one health
thought machine goes now at the minimum
so sorry that's not even - do I want to
look at my health alright so I'm fine
that's great so I'm gonna put these
pucks away and then and then I'm
probably gonna lean on you a little bit
for like how I have like do you think
they're poisonous like should I bring
like something to stave off poison am I
good with like two herbs or should I
bring like actually I don't
oh my god I don't have a lot of health
I'm thinking ahead here because well
member no but remember over there
there's a few more in the hallway coming
up
you've got a lot of green herbs these
are blue first of all no I do not have
three I have one two three there's like
one more three if three herbs and then I
have a combo so technically have four
yes I'd say bring the combo I bring
these combi okay I don't know what items
you have coming up they might be so Shay
I have a shotgun submachine guns and 37
regular bullies is that enough or do I
need like acid rounds I know it's a
reasonable question think we could try
it and see how it goes and then if I
need more firepower try again
cuz I just saved so like yeah oops I
know like their hearts coming up but
because of our time today I don't know
if we'll get to a part where we need the
grenades
is it the wall because I'm planning on
going after that wall today that's my
plan
sorry the wall yeah that thing that
gross thing that I saw I've got it know
where I am alright so I'm taking a left
and then all the zombies are in this
hallway in this like L and then through
this door here is where I saw that gross
thing I'm pretty sure there was a
sweeper as well remember I hit you as
scared to you and you went into this
room I do remember but I think it was in
this area yeah and I'm going I wish you
guys could see my fingers I'm going down
to the L so I'm gonna leave this room
and I'm gonna take it left
and I'm just gonna like shoot a lot of
these zombies that's my plan okay so
there's a lot of zombies in here so the
first thing I'm gonna do is combine
these Bulls and just start shooting
because I know there's a lot I feel
confident that there's a lot dodging
once you power I'm gonna kill everyone
because it's a angled hallway and
there's like no way for me to see
there's like no way for me to determine
[Music]
how like I remember it being bad like
there was a lot yeah you brown it the
water there was like 10 more oh no I'm
out of bullies alright so I feel like
there's like six more there's like oh
sorry
before you go any farther yeah little a
knee oh yeah baby go kill them and then
go back because I think you need that
paper wait you go oh you're right there
were more orbs
[Music]
choppin
or machine gun shotgun it seems better
because I might need the ranch for once
show yourself go ahead
[Music]
I hope you like your own blood go see
you later girl
who was that what's his hat all right so
let me pick these up
oh nice okay good so can I combine two
if I combine two herbs greens it's still
more powerful than the green separately
correct
is that true so I have space correct but
I have no red so I'm inclined to combine
them what like worst-case scenario what
if you find two red herbs you miss out
on like okay so this is where I'm at
this has no bullet so I could get rid of
it and bring something else or what do
you think I'll see you were like don't
you have to bring something else but
then you're like every way that died I
need to bring a die okay anything else I
don't feel like I have enough firepower
to take on this wall do you think I do
if I keep going there's like something
[ __ ] up and I'm trying to remember
what it is
maybe yeah that's alright we'll be good
it takes up two slots let's do it
don't behind well we're going to Train
like doing this whole game line but
I don't know what's ahead I just
remember from cheating last episode that
there was something past here I'm
telling you there's something past year
just to keep it as blind as possible but
in the interest still sometimes check
stuff out here it is so yeah so there's
this lady there's a booby lady and then
we're on the shotgun in hangouts to the
back
should I get whatever's in there oh it
doesn't let me yeah I think you can push
that
[Music]
where am i pushing it also do I want
these because then I got to go back I
guess I had to go back anyway yeah sorry
it's too late the decision was made damn
it
let me there we go alright and then I
can push this but where and why like I
think you can climb on that cabinet so
it looks like a map for the record I
don't it's not necessary stop saying
it's cracked I know
oh sorry no sorry you don't climb out I
think pushing on to the crack will it'll
sink into the floor and then you can
grab them out
I don't think I think I've space it
might be your Maps
I love maps let's check the map all
right so if I just push it this way and
then back that'll work
yes find out
[Music]
[Music]
that's what you want go farther into the
crackling yeah it's just saying like I
can't undo this you know what I mean
like when I push it to the left here
this is it yeah it's not but I won't it
[Music]
okay [ __ ] it up okay the building's
thought go what
okay 30 20s gangster alright um it was
somewhere in here and I don't remember
where let's check the map is it this red
door here was red me and that means that
candle I wouldn't go into that big room
yet that looks like very much like a
boss go down the hallway before
dead bodies or hazmat suits all right so
this is a dead end so let's just scope
it out is it yeah check the map looks
like the original game changer
Oh should I take these this took a
little dangerous I actually remember
this there's magnum rounds here it's
some way so take the jewel but you don't
oh I can't take the jewel I'm full you
could just go died and box it's pretty
close by okay so do it yeah I think I'm
gonna die open that door quick I don't I
don't think that's a quick door yeah
there's just a tiny closet room
according to the map to believe so it's
not you we did this member oh no it was
another air vented door so you're just
going down into the laboratory but yeah
you go back
what am i doing let's go back I was just
curious it looked like this is this
place I was telling you about
Oh gotcha cool that's like with the
gross thing what was that what the
Dumbledore if I do a huge look like a
box it is but I don't think I can get in
there yet because it's red oh it's
locked right yeah so this is the way I'm
gonna go all right yeah we'll go drop
off items I feel like I am teaching you
today yeah you are should I look at them
I should investigate thanks Chris
they're gross he fills up the whole
doorframe almost it's a bulky man what
can you say you know
[Music]
I got confused okay so up is the way I
came this music what it sounded like a
Batman flashback oh I was gonna say have
you ever seen flight of the navigator
no okay it's this old movie about like a
kid who finds a UFO and in the UFO is
like I'm not sure an AI or some kind of
robot entity and they like form a
friendship that's at the point the point
is is when something scary happens in
the movie it's this song almost it's
like and that's like how they like
stress you out and it's really good and
everyone should see flight of the
navigator you should see it so I don't
need these bullets I didn't bring this
gun submachine guns I don't think you
need yet save those for boss I don't
know you're not coming up but there's a
wall I don't believe you I think I'm
underprepared but I'm gonna do it
because I haven't gone that far so if I
die my blood is on your hands
number you death number 17 oh yeah I
check the stats people liked how you uh
that was a Babe Ruth tit okay so I'm
gonna go through here yes yes and then I
mean you still need to do tiger things
with one of the jewels oh right I didn't
get the jewel she told me to get the
jewel too late I just keep doing this
can I just go back and get it later
yeah I really want to see it
I'm waiting for this Wow you see it you
see it
see bugs
oh I told you it's not a wall that's the
worst way to start the wasn't tentacle
from the thing that crash the hell
it's like a beehive wall moving
I think I got hurt getting hurt oh no I
don't want these do I I can take one but
no don't yet you're coming back to play
all right so I'm in a new area should I
do this I'm going in jam-pack is shorter
episode oh my god oh my god
[Music]
where the [ __ ] am I
probably need some sort of item in here
you know I'll say did you investigate
battery I'm trying
he doesn't has got nothing to say he's a
very vocal man and he's got nothing to
say as twins Alexei and I are two sides
of a coin a design is carved under the
name of Alexia heart I feel like we
should write this down
yeah but the heart Speight give a pen in
your purse
no all right am i selling its heart ace
of spades
[Applause]
[Music]
American Airlines King hat okay King hat
is that what you call him yeah it's a
hat for a king okay there's a button I
guess the heart well I feel like they
wouldn't tell you what to do
okay can you use the paperweight we're
here yeah those are the same things on
the neighborly
[Music]
I guess we just gotta close that what's
down here
like what's this everything in the
corner
[Music]
it's a lot going on over here
work continues on the T Veronica virus
and which I extracted from the queen ant
protect the clean
I have finally implanted the virus in my
own butt and I've discovered how to
utilize its power I'll suppress the
activity of the virus to an ultra low
temp my calculations indicate that it
will take 15 years for our body will
gain immunity until then I have no
choice but to trust the capsule that I
will be in so to that inept but loyal
soldier who is my brother
woo when I awaken I will be the queen
and the T Veronica virus will be
unleashed upon the entire world by my
children every last creature on earth
will exist to serve me woof
she is evil let's try
it's a wall
okay we can go the other side catwalk
[Music]
it's a big room but he's got nothing to
say isn't that weird anomalies like
can't shut up normally it's like there's
a crack in the floor let's tell there's
like blood do you have your lighter
equipped or in your inventory maybe
that'll deter them you doubt it but I'll
do it
yeah a run or no oh yeah well they
stopped the tack up nope nope they're
still attacking well there's a lot of
herbs going on yeah herb Alicia's I hear
a bad guy I only have a shotgun and a
salt rifle what shotgun I just feel like
those are best for that the big guys
does it stunts them do you know what I
mean yeah
yes our phone you want if there's any
more of those guys I want my shotgun yes
but you also want your salt for fossils
[Music]
stop it yeah no this isn't good
and it's so dark sorry I feel bad about
using it but I really I really want to
keep my shotty oh I [ __ ] I got hurt you
could just use that green you have now
okay we never expected the paper right
by the way maybe okay let's do that
well Sarina
[Music]
I mean it looks like a die
[Music]
it's really freakin dark in here so I'm
gonna have a hard time seeing after
discovering the remains of the ancient
virus within the genes of a clean ant I
have been concentrating on the research
of ants the ecosystem of the ants seems
truly ideal there is one queen one clean
and the soldier and the worker ants and
the queen slaves they dedicate their
lives to clean the queen the death of
the clean because it means doom for the
whole anthill the soldier and the worker
ants can be easily replaced as long as
the queen ant is alive plan is exactly
the same relationship between myself and
the other ignorant masses Wow I have
succeeded in creating an ideal virus by
implementing the cleans ant into the
mother virus
[Music]
use the otherwise useless father as a
test subject
the virus caused a rapid change
triggering a complete destruction of his
brain furthermore is that a special type
of poison gas was generated inside his
body that the blue herb had no effect
against because of this I created an
antidote in case of an emergency and
stored it inside the weapon chemical
warehouse on the b2 floor I've decided
to name this virus with unimaginable
potential T Veronica virus when I find
out how I can utilize the power of the
wonderful virus my great research will
finally be complete alright okay
so I need to find a way to get that
antivirus because oh [ __ ] I cannot
[ __ ] see
I left left nope the wall bigger door
[Music]
you'll see you did I see everything in
here like did I investigate everything
[Music]
like what's in here God where are you
[Music]
I'm in the other room you dick yeah
that's better now you need your lighter
I think once you killed I knew it it
must have been hooked up to a
supercomputer thanks Chris
how does it know that I don't know ooh
what's in that file
Oh ending the show oh cool I think I
have 30 rounds that's good I feel like
that was worth coming in here yeah maybe
use my shotgun and I don't have my
regular gun is that all that was in here
[Music]
what's some valuable stuff environmental
storytelling for the end oh wait there's
narrowed down the door
so this is back the way I came right I
see it - I can see it
[Music]
I say that's worth getting that going
back
because then I got to come back through
this area again right really
mister don't save it
[Music]
or you can go back to the Edit box
offensive boy no I don't all right so
I'm confused I'm at a dead end now okay
so I'm gonna come in this great and then
I'm gonna get this and then we're gonna
go back to we're on the other side so I
missed something
I mean it doesn't seem like it's good
it's annoying
all right so we're going back to the
paperweight room yeah yep and then what
[Music]
so go back to the you read that report
right you said there are two sides of
the same coin
yeah could either mean you do the
opposite of what the computer tells you
or suicides the same coin
so do crown oh okay so you wrote this
down right yeah heart you have it
written down yeah okay I got it I think
no I got it I got it
so I'm so smart so we're doing the
opposite side of this got it okay so
heart rate was first heart was first
okay so the opposite of heart is
American Airline write that down what
was next it was the Spade okay here's
the Spade the opposite Spade is Kings
hat and then what was next part
[Music]
ASA spades right okay that should be it
okay great I'm on board American
Airlines okay
American Airlines crown King's heart can
you put the dice right sure I can put
anything in their house bigger than I
thought
oh my god is this a boss so I don't know
these deputies got a ring that you take
and you have a free space now oh good
now to figure out what to do with that
and the way back
is that he's one of them well that was
easy let me inspect both of these just
in case has actually never inspected the
wing
[Music]
it's very uninteresting appears to be
dragonfly wings it seems to be part of
something so it's changed to winged
object
oh [ __ ]
okay so I just removed the metal
wait I mean
beckylyn I was on her role though yeah
you were firing on all cylinders all
right let's go back to savor of anyway
okay the ring seems important
[Music]
I was trying to make a duel but no
[Music]
I think it's worth coming back for the
lights you have that listo
okay [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
because you do the title there's a what
what you got to do something with a
tiger a thing because I know you can't
get back around I think you need it
right it can be just sitting here with a
[ __ ] lighter feel as if my volume is
really low today looks like it's super
low are you worried about it kind of
dude again
dear that looks a little better if it is
I'll try to I can hear you yeah you can
hear me I turned you up just now but it
might be too late because it's been like
halfway through the episode we'll figure
it out you need to talk louder than idea
no problem this is the box so I'm gonna
go in here I'm gonna get rid of I mean
should I keep the jewel like don't get
rid of it for now you don't think I need
it no okay so what about the wing you
can get rid of em for now we're just
going back down to get that herb and the
Tiger stuff so you don't really need
much at all oh my gosh this item box is
crammed 'add can use that valve handle
back behind here did you try it already
octo valve handle let's try it
um give her that herb and the bloom
green both I feel like it's good to keep
you're going back to an area you just
played out really and get rid of the
assault rifle I'd say it needs much
basis I'm gonna take my gun then my
handgun because I got 30 rounds you
passed it just check if it's I think
that's a square as opposed to an octagon
or maybe that's not even a socket maybe
we tried that already
all right so let's go solve your lighter
quick just so you know oh I know okay
yeah I do the tiger and get that herb
down did you get all the other herbs
over on the other side of the catwalk I
think pretty positive are these yours
yeah those are my Sunny's I look
fabulous they look good
yeah they don't Jacob Lana I don't think
they're not knockoffs but they're not
like nice cuz I don't have any money
which Jule
oh I guess take them well left what are
you basing this off of no I don't we
don't Stu do the right thing every time
just just take a look nice
[Music]
ooh that looks like it can combine with
a valve can you combine that with a
valve right now
[Music]
take the other one the other one's gotta
be too magnum rounds
we don't have a Magnum gun I know I'm
just I'm not saying you should take no
I'm just saying just to make sure it's
not something yeah please do not fill up
space with us
so no don't take them no should I put
the jewel back yeah I actually got the
socket I just go get that green herb and
then get out of here
was it it's here yeah I don't even know
if the letters doing anything banks we
feel a little safer though I like it
just because I can see better I have a
really hard time seeing in this game we
have a lot of back lights in this room
yeah and I feel like I just a GameSpot
daily studio it was this way [ __ ] was it
this way
nice you're pretty flush with health
that's great
I mean alright so where am I going now
back at the item room there was that
room there was that like freezer thing
before the save room where the sweeper
was that you never investigated because
the sweepers right let's get the sweeper
should I save yeah just I don't want to
redo all this stuff at the same time I
don't want to like lose all my pucks
but I think I have a decent amount and
you're also like this isn't the last
episode by any means but you're like
toward the end of the game this is back
home so this door still locked this door
is locked I can try it or it's a bit
dangerous
biohazard key okay so there was a
youtube comment with a warning for me I
can't remember what it was though it was
something like you're getting towards
the end of the game so you need to get
like you need to like conserve ammo and
stuff like that but I feel like I'm
doing really well because I haven't used
any of my grenade I'm sorry
I can check though all right so
[Music]
I'm actually not sure [ __ ] killing it
at this game Knievel here we go I owe
that song wasn't blink-182 by the way it
was lit I know somebody brought that up
I
[Music]
nice yeah I can use that now behind you
or is in at the other room yeah oh so
now it's a square
oh right didn't we find a square one we
couldn't put it in yes I don't remember
where but either way just to
double-check maybe should try it behind
oh did you try that once you combine
them yes okay cool
sorry I'm looking for that youtube
comment no it's fine it was like go down
a bunch of people agreed that a blind
playthrough is better I mean it's like
more stressful that's for sure well
someone said Mike just guiding Mary
step-by-step would take all the fun out
of a great go down
the end is nigh we're about to crank it
up to 11
there's some cryptic tips make sure
Chris is ready to take on an army so I
didn't read all of this because I was
like I didn't know if there was like
some spoilers in there but undefined
variable was like I need to like this
this part seems really important
bringing up health because you gotta
like you gotta like not let her die so I
need to put enough health back in the
box which she can fully restore twice
let's just bring enough health not put
him in the box
well I can't I guess that is the
question right is like you haven't I do
any other item no no do I put them in
the box so that when I become Claire I
can get them this is the opposite of a
blind playthrough what you're doing
right now yeah I don't know
that's one saying you know I'm saying
cuz like if I take them with me then she
can't have them yeah but you have enough
to take some with you and leave you're
gonna use Chris again so you need some
for both of them no matter what you're
gonna have so alright so I've saved and
I've got a gun and I'm gonna go I have a
stop Nathan Shepherd the tiger nation
scheppers one who does their statistics
thank you doing God's work that Tiger
statue has two things for you one you'll
need to progress the other won't be
useful all and will only serve as an
annoying reminder as always thank you
Nathan Shepherd on YouTube oh nice good
job I think wait
hurrah
ding-dong the dick is dead we did it
okay cool
whoa where am I I sincerely apologize to
everybody for my those audio problems
made me really low luckily enough I
don't really usually say anything
worthwhile so hopefully they can bear
there's another couple there's a one
more wing thing remember string things
the the key that was gummy candy things
that came on the thin white cardboard
that you peeled them off but they were
in designs it was like the same company
that made gushers and fruit roll-ups did
them what they're amazing another
carousel member earlier in the game
there's one in the mansion I do you have
enough room to get that oh oh [ __ ] why
not put the ink ribbons away idiot um
reload your shotgun anger that's not
gonna do anything I'm such a but I know
um can I ride it tell me I can get on
this pony oh my god what a waste so I
need you in the water there's some in
the water now I come up on a comment
says also please use the SMGs you aren't
going to need them for boss fights
that's what the name launchers for well
whatever well I did kind of use it yeah
you know we're good like he's got
nothing no comment no there's gotta be
oh I see you're trying to do yeah
Krista's always got a smug Jim Halpert
kind of yeah can you go down there uh
hold on I don't think you lined up
completely
still and I guess not okay what a weird
room okay so I got this door here I'll
just keep scanning you to comments this
looks like a scary door
what should I do should I go in it is
this a boss fight okay so I'm a little
worried based on YouTube no I don't
think so wait bring up your map look
there's our 95th episode by the way oh
my god I don't think you want to go in
it yet I come going what time is it
okay so do it because of time constraint
you're coming up toward the end of the
episode let's do it did you just save
yes yeah you might as well I think this
is where Claire is
well okay so here's another question
then should I like have these items on
me right like should I have an assault
rifle the save room is like literally
next door spare no expense you know sure
like it's right oh is that a boss oh
[ __ ] I don't that's what I'm trying to
say see this is what I'm tempted to look
something up and I just saved so it's
not like a big deal like I'm not too
stressed out about it let's just go for
it okay I'm gonna get an SMG or
something it always catches me out when
you become the gung-ho one I got it I
like it nothing can kill me
I'm the last death girl this is it okay
so I don't need the valve if you're
going back there you think so
you don't definitely because I really
what I remember where that valve square
thing was it was near the magnet boom
okay I got three [ __ ] wing
okay I mean I could be wrong I mean I've
been wrong often and then this SMG which
I'm gonna try to pizza floss I thought
you're gonna need handgun rounds but if
it's not a boss you might hey did she
did he say SMG or assault rifle on some
of you so I wanted to put this back and
get the SMG you also have handgun rounds
and no handgun hit me in again
oh that's okay don't be stupid all right
let's go this wall tastes good I like I
have two guns just makes me feel
important like Steve what does he say oh
yes just [ __ ] racism with bullets
okay
don't get scared now this is gonna be
such an anticlimax is there's nothing
what the [ __ ] you're back in the um the
mansion from before
huh okay okay
interesting hmm what is that it's like
Nickelodeon goo what is that Rosie
O'Donnell's about touch it just smell it
taste it oh it's it's car [ __ ] uh let's
get her out of there oh my god
tool where's si I have an item just
shotgunner are you a nice um yes I don't
know you don't hey it doesn't look like
you have anything use the herb try to
just kidding that go upstairs I guess
that's the only way oh you can unlock
that double door by the way while you're
here I think I would assume he takes a
left what a pointless lobby there's one
door out of - oh all right okay so I
need a biohazard key to get through
there all right so I'm going up these
stairs
did you check both sides of a stereotype
you're anyone's side right
well they're connected I know I just
didn't you didn't check the back toward
like if there's anything here nothing no
nothing behind that column yeah cool
okay that's easy
I'm serious yeah also well I don't think
you want a free Claire yet though cuz
you didn't use the valve handle I'm
pretty sure you use that before you do
the claire stuff cuz once you free her I
think you're using her or at least like
with her I don't know we go three weird
holes open mm-hmm they're at the boys
finger oh man's ear and girl's bosom so
what like a broach and earring and the
ring
can you put oh you don't have it okay so
maybe that's what we're doing next
with the fit with the wings no no well
maybe I was
his Alexander's brooch I have the ring
or not Alexander's you Alexander's their
dads you have Alfred's of jewel this is
locked and there's nothing I really
don't
oh it's locked okay good so oh what's
that
all right Jimmy key is that it's you had
a fleet free clear this is a weird
upstairs like one nor made this mansion
a big dumb idiot I guess go cut Claire
out no cuz you're gonna you're gonna
trigger like being Claire and you don't
want to do that yeah why not because you
have other stuff to do I'm telling you
that what other stuff just go back don't
do it yet what stuff do I have to do use
the valve handle to get something else
all right so if I want helpful Knievel
viewers hear that okay giving me Warren
so before I go using judiciously alright
so we go to what didn't you tell me do I
have the vales yes connect it to sake
you got to go back to its before all
this toward like the magnum room sorry
to bring it up I do not have the valve
handle I know it's in the item box oh
you're saying I could just get the item
box
yeah the back of the box no I just need
oh I see yeah you need the valve handle
I was telling you you need the valve
handle what what
chill out my face says it all
so does mine pull my finger says oh I
don't know okay cool
I don't all right so what am I getting
rid of and what am i adding I'm gonna
get the valve handle yeah I'm gonna keep
my SMG in the shotgun in case I
accidentally trigger one of those
[ __ ] yeah get rid of the handgun I'd
say in case you run there's anything
else out there get rid of the handgun
yeah I don't see it being useful you
already have a shotgun smg's and get rid
of a green herb what about the knife I
only need that to free Claire yeah what
the [ __ ] you already have a combat knife
maybe they just put that one there in
case you didn't get that earlier okay Oh
maybe it was on how many combat knives
you have three oh wow
I wonder if they do that because if you
have it and then you switch to the other
person you lose it so they had to do
that in case you got stuck yeah good
point
okay anyway um you know I hope you need
a hand got no other rounds or the green
earth
[Music]
yeah this music just doesn't light up
all right so you're saying that's all I
need yes so then go back up the other
elevator I'm gonna go to the other
elevator we're gonna use that valve to
get something and then after that are we
ready to like free Claire and become
Claire yeah I guess that could be the
next episode probably but yeah and then
that might be the Matt last episode next
week being optimistic no not even any
obviously I think it will Alexia
oh I forgot good reflex especially
considering I forgot I just I got out
[Music]
where do you think he is gonna stop
juicing yourself probably in front of
you
[Music]
that's so much more terrifying when I
take my headphones off because I don't
know when he's coming yeah might as well
I mean I can wait
I'm okay okay do you know where I'm
going or do I bring that up because I'd
really like to not [ __ ] around because
it I think
I'm because of sixty five percent sure
it's the door to the to the left on the
map so to cook Chris is right Chris is
right yeah because yeah yeah it is if
you go back to the other a mess the
catwalks where you started in Antarctica
all right stored there I think I was
right there should be a lift in here yes
okay so taking this lift yes take that
up and then I'm pretty sure that's where
you saw the square valve okay way that's
going down yes it is oh yeah okay I
can't use that go god I can't see
through there maybe or check that box
all right other door [ __ ] honey maybe
what's that pink thing all the list okay
sorry sorry no it's fine go back off the
lift okay I think we went too far this
is down I can't believe we didn't get
the Magnum look how much it's like
laughing at us okay all right so it's
not here so I got to go through those
it's it's around here
oh sorry wrong lift up that lifts this
should go up and then the valve eh yes
yes yes the valve handles up there
you'll get there there's a ladder
steaming I really hope I'm right I've
been wrong so too many damn lifts ah
drain the water get whatever that thing
is and you got probably a key item god I
hope it's a fire extinguisher
if only Chris wasn't a baby and would
just walk through the fire oh my god
what sorry to clean the tank exchange
the water just yeah I got it
I'm sorry I read I'm a reader a
bibliophile
sounds like he's peeing
what is that okay okay
[Music]
hit me keep going to hit me they have to
turn around will that kill me
you should heal yeah he's gonna get you
have your submachine guns equipped oh
that's why you're here
[Music]
nice damn did you see it oh Jesus that
camera [ __ ] you over I know you handled
that well I'm probably you Jesus Christ
they got me there I did not expect that
okay that was a good way - so you got
the crane key which I don't know I'm
assuming it's something in the mansion
that doesn't make sense I really the
next thing you do is cut Claire out and
become Claire I'm pretty sure what a
weird place to keep Claire behind the
stairs it's kind of creepy remember
behind the stairs in the first game was
the dungeon nope don't go down that
right go that door yeah that's back to
the safe room but I can't use the crane
key now no I I don't think I don't think
so I don't remember a crane unless it's
in this room dang if I become clear then
I can't use it right you're not gonna
become Claire for the rest of the game
you become Claire for a little bit you
like switch I'm pretty sure you switch
back and forth at least once more okay
so what you're saying is is I'm gonna
save become clear and then I'll become
ya start the next episode become Claire
and then so presumably you so what we
could do it that'll be on the next
episode yeah once you save get alfred's
jewel put that into the painting just to
get it out of your inventory and then
you need presumably something like an
earring from Alexander and a broach or
something from okay so we need because
this is the scanning area and I'm not
[ __ ] around
where am i shotgun elevators the pink
room okay so I'm going to Chris's all
the way up yeah
[Music]
yeah I just I don't I get the puzzle
puzzles no puzzles no puzzles
you've seen that chardee macdennis okay
cool you know I'm talking about yeah
that's a good mantra for the show team
the puzzles no puzzles no puzzles no
puzzles
I don't mind puzzles it's the guys I
don't like ya know kind of it no
commenting fighting zombies zombies
we don't want combat because I'm running
out of shotgun shells cool save room
save and we're done for today yes you
did yeah we're getting there we're
coming up on what res equals zero
technically which oh you'll be happy to
know this I think I've mentioned this
before but that's in the HD collect the
origins collection which means you tank
controls are redone like remake was I'm
gonna play through that before I empty
my inventory so she has access to all
these items I don't know that that's
necessarily how that works but I mean
it's a good thought like I'll keep them
too though and you have enough health
where I think you could do to her she's
gonna be injured I'm fairly certain keep
poisoned things in here for sure I'd say
like take one other greenair for Chris
I'm gonna take Lux and I'm gonna take
this combat knife because I need it and
that will remind have a lot of pucks you
have 14 other ones that are still in
your inventory
hot-diggity-dog I think our fear before
starting this game I don't want to jinx
it toward the end but I think our fear
led to us being overly conservative with
ammo which worked out and helped
although at the beginning of the game we
wouldn't we weren't killing anybody
until people were like you guys got to
start shooting people done sweet
awesome have a great weekend y'all yeah
thanks everybody
visitors your first episode we have a
whole other ninety four episode you can
go catch up on oh my god it's so crazy I
think that this is our a resonable game
we've been playing through next we'll be
resonable zero this was a penultimate
possibly or next the penultimate you
know it's a bit for one of those few
times that's actually accurate but yeah
we'll be back next week and enjoy the
rest of your Saturday
thank you everybody shout out to the
people who you know regularly keep up
with our stats and do some of the
occasional fan art and stuff that's
always yeah let me know that's part of
our week totally ruining this and we're
all gonna die and yes thank you for
keeping me on my toes Jamie well bye
everyone bye
[Music]